élections régionales à droite comme à
gauche le message est clair il faut
faire barrage au rassemblement national
mais quand sera-t-il au moment d'élire
les présidents de région souvenez-vous
en 1998 une partie du centre de la
droite n'avait pas hésité à s'allier
avec l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque quatre élus udf accepte une
alliance avec le front national au
moment d'élire les présidents de région
branle bas de combat à droite le député
rpr françois fillon dans un
avertissement à ceux qui pactisent ray
avec l'extrême droite
[Musique]
ce que nous avons toujours dit que nous
ferons c'est à dire qu'ils seront exclus
de notre mouvement
malgré cette mise en garde les quatre
élus de droite font la sourde oreille
premier exemple jean pierre soisson
candidat udf en bourgogne il est élu à
la tête de la région grâce aux neuf voix
du fn
à gauche on s'insurge c'est la bronca
dans l'hémicycle n'êtes vous pas
aujourd'hui pieds poings liés entre eux
n'est pas cette impression d'être pieds
jamais jean pierre soisson est exclu du
df en languedoc roussillon
même stratégie jacques blanc candidat
udf est en ballottage défavorable face
au socialiste georges frêche mais
c'était sans compter sur les treize voix
du fn qui lui permet d'être réélu
président de la région
une alliance que jacques blanc nie en
bloc je n'ai je le répète signé aucune
alliance aucun accord et je n'ai fait
aucune complaisance puisque je n'ai fait
que reprendre les thèmes de ma campagne
lui aussi est exclu du parti de centre
droit après jacques blanc charles baur
en picardie une région promise au
candidat communiste gérard lalot
mais le candidat udf passe également un
accord avec le fn la gauche demande sa
démission
à droite aussi la pilule a du mal à
passer chez certains élus charles baur
et réélu avant d'être à son tour exclu
de l'udf ah bon quelques minutes
seulement après l'annnonce du scrutin
bien sûr que je la regrette surtout que
c'est sur les valeurs de l'udf et sur le
programme de l'udf que je suis élu je
pense que les choses s'arrangent
dernière alliance avec le fn celle de
charles millon région rhône alpes
au moment du vote coup de tonnerre bruno
gollnisch alors conseiller régional fn
appelle à voter pour le candidat udf
millions est réélu grâce aux voix
d'extrême droite mais réfute lui aussi
tout accord politique marchandage qui
serait même sanction pour charles millon
qui est évincé de l'udf
sur les quatre élus trois seront
définitivement exclu seul jacques blanc
sera réintégré par la suite
[Musique]